President Biden arriving in El Paso
Texas this afternoon right now he's on
his way to tour a migrant detention
center and before that the president met
with border enforcement at the Port of
Entry facility speaking with officers
and seeing demonstrations of inspections
and drug seizures that take place daily
and moments after he got off of Air
Force One Texas governor Greg Abbott
greeted him handing him a scathing
letter that read in part quote your
visit to the southern border is 20
billion dollars to little and two years
too late here's the governor moments ago
after he spoke to the president
I told him how thousands of Texans have
lost their lives tens of thousands of
Texas have been had their life destroyed
by his open border policies but most
importantly a provided telling something
that he asked for
the president asked for solutions from
Republicans in the letter that I gave
him I provided five solutions that
already exist it just so happens he's
two years at about 20 billion dollars
too late what did the president say to
you he said he wanted to work with us
okay well that was Texas governor Greg
Abbott uh just after he met with the
president he handed him a letter uh
basically a list of Demands that he
would like to see the president respond
to I want to take it out to our panel
right now uh historic visit first visit
by President Biden to the Border as
president uh he is greeted there by Greg
Abbott who I might say was just invited
last night I mean this trip was has been
planned for months Texas governor Greg
Abbott's aide received an email last
night saying hey we're coming to the
Border would the president like to meet
with us and Governor Abbott hands the
president this letter Charlie you had a
chance to take a look at the letter uh
what did you think about it what's the
most important in there that the
governor asked the president of course
in the letter uh he talked about the
fact that you have Property Owners along
the border whose lives and whose
property has been absolutely destroyed
uh by the the uh by by the policies at
the border he also talked about the fact
that you have uh his policies have been
entirely empowered the drug cartels who
have complete operational control the
Border but the most important thing in
there are the things the the five
demands that he makes and all the five
demands that he makes are simple demands
of law that are already in the law that
that Joe Biden is already supposed to be
doing and so it's just sort of a it's a
reminder that and and Governor Abbott
says this in the letter that that you
know for all of the problems at the
border uh the uh president Trump solved
the immediate crisis at the border
stopped the flow which is to me the most
pressing part of the problem and Joe
Biden systematically went through and
undid every single one of those things
to create the human catastrophe that we
now have at the border yeah the numbers
of people coming over just astonishing
why don't we put some of those numbers
up now if we can we have the fiscal 2023
numbers compared to 2022. take a look at
those numbers so for 2023 718 000 plus
swamping the year before uh 518 000 then
you have your daily border average of
Crossing
um you know if it is an astonishing
number it's almost 7 000 people 6 800
people crossing the border every day uh
it is uh unbelievable I don't want to
take a listen to a former border patrol
Chief this is Rodney Scott really
putting these numbers into context so we
can all understand them
it's off the charts I believe a prior
secretary under Obama said over a
thousand a day is four thousand in
custody it makes him lose sleep people
need to put that into perspective so
every single one of those those let's
just call the number for right now
that's about an hour a man-hour minimum
of processing that literally wipes out
all the border patrol agents on the line
unreal uh guy uh it's great that the
president is visiting the Border today
is anything going to change do you think
are any are there going to be any new
policies to address whatever he sees
today well they've announced their new
policy package late last week I'm
skeptical that it will really deal with
the heart of the problem in a number of
different ways the numbers that we just
put up on the screen are extraordinary I
mean if you go back to the what's like
the first three months roughly first
hundred days of last fiscal year it was
over half a million people encountered
at the border that was a blowout number
totally unacceptable and then thus far
this fiscal year it's more than two
hundred thousand more yeah I mean that I
think that helps underscore there it is
that underscores right there what you're
looking at the scope of this problem
this is a mind-blowing magnitude that
we're talking about and I'm glad that
Governor Abbott prepared that letter
simple one page a few bullet points of
solutions handing it directly to a
president who has gone out of his way
way to ignore this problem he has not
even pretended to care about this
problem Abbott understood he had one
shot a moment to try to get his position
across and he's done so and I think in
that letter the most important phrase
three words in the letter remain in
Mexico that is the number one policy
under President Trump that the reversal
of which has been particularly harmful
and I read a Reuters story today that
was borderline propaganda and it was all
framing it as the Republicans unwilling
to work with the Democrats on
immigration and that's really the
problem and they said this intransigence
I'm paraphrasing leaves President Biden
with few good options and it's just not
true we could talk about legislative
Solutions at some point he could
reinstitute remain in Mexico tomorrow as
a policy and things would get a lot
better he's not going to do that and he
should have to answer why yeah well
Tammy I want to ask you also about these
numbers but I want to take a listen to
something that the White House Press
Secretary said on the way to El Paso
aboard Air Force first one take a listen
to this
the number of people attempting to cross
the border unlawfully in El Paso is now
down by over 70 percent and that has
been since mid-December since the
president launched the Venezuela parole
process the average daily number of
Venezuelans Nationals encounter at the
border in El Paso alone is now a quarter
of what it was prior to the launch so
again the president's border uh
enforcement measures are working
Tammy the president's border enforcement
measures are working we saw the numbers
we saw them we heard from the former
border patrol Chief about how
unbelievable they are how does she get
away with a statement like that she gets
away with it because the Fox News
audience knows these numbers and the
reality of it but there was a study for
just I think just a month ago indicating
about six percent of Americans
understood and and realized the the
magnitude of what was happening at the
border they didn't know about these
numbers when you think about like you
mentioned the the Reuters story I think
that they're looking at media that
reinforces that rhetoric and that's all
they see and so they're noticing that
for that base if only six you know six
percent
um you know no then there it's working
for them and the question by the way was
like how many people across the border
illegally last year and only six percent
were close to they had any any real
grass and maybe it's you know we have
more than six percent as we know of the
audience but that's the issue is that
they're looking at this as a news cycle
what kind of information are they
controlling versus the reality and I
think that one of the reason is why this
visit was important for the Democrats
was that it takes off the table the
argument you've never been but it also
then in a cleaned up environment lets
them reinforce if you know this is how
this might be looking and I'm doing a
good job and if he does reverse some of
his positions and there's an actual
change in the numbers like Romaine New
Mexico he can take credit for that he
can say look we really are making the
the difference here but I think that
really this the Democrats for a long
time starting with Barack Obama have
been about winning a new cycle winning
the the public argument and the rhetoric
and keeping Americans ignorant as to
what's going on all right so we're
hearing from the Press pool on the
ground there in El Paso some comments
that the president just made the
president said this quote they need a
lot of resources and we're going to get
it for them
um okay he hears that and he thinks
spending I get to spend more money
that's all he's talking about but the
follow-up question for Korean John
Pierre would have been okay it was
specifically which policies of the
president have uh have according to you
uh lowered the number of people crossing
the border which is a lie but there's a
tremendous the two most valuable things
that make people really uh do well in
politics one is is to be completely
Shameless and these people are
completely ashamed the other is to be
completely untethered from reality or
the truth and the White House says these
things because they have no shame and
because they don't want to uh they don't
care about the truth but also because
the as you point out Tammy the people in
our business just don't you know it's
like we're the only ones that hold them
accountable for this stuff or not even
holding accountable reporting the actual
events that are occurring you don't it
doesn't matter what your politics are
these are facts and also Democrats have
now gone after him about the condition
uh the mayor of El Paso you know a
democratic officials locally maybe and
the shift when it comes to Hispanics and
Hispanic voting trends when it affects
them in that way they'll care otherwise
not and that's the most important point
is that is the fact that the the reason
that he reversed himself on this and
decided to go to the border is because
even he realizes this is an important
issue to his voters well speaking of
people in the community and people who
need resources let's hear from some
people in the community and how this
entire situation has affected where they
live
we're proud Americans yes we are but we
want it to be done legally and the
Assumption by a lot of people this
Administration and our congresswoman
that we're okay with what's happening to
our city right now is absolutely
outrageous November a house got busted
for trafficking migrants across the
street our partners in Border Patrol are
now constantly pulled off the line to
help process these migrants which has
made has made the Border unsecure
they're actually using our city services
it's not just isolated the border patrol
agents now the city the county and the
state are involved in taking care of
these illegal aliens it doesn't matter
where you go in El Paso there's illegals
walking everywhere
so guy forgotten in a lot of the
coverage on this is how this Calamity is
affecting people who live there yep so
two points number one the president
reportedly just talked about resources
probably some additional resources are
appropriate it's more much more about
the policy that cannot be said enough
not so much spending some key reversals
secondly that Montage that we just
played I hope that President Biden
during his time on the ground there will
actually listen to some of those precise
people either them specifically or
people like them he needs to hear that
message whether he's actually going to
have that if the handlers have sort of
orchestrated this thing and
choreographed it differently then that
would be a missed opportunity I would
say and I will probably learn more about
that in the hours and days to come yeah
hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now